hace poco me hicieron una pregunta y hoy
se las voy a hacer ustedes es retórica
por si acaso alguna vez has tenido un
trabajo hoy voy a hablar un poco sobre
tomar responsabilidades antes de los 18
años y los beneficios y la importancia
de hacerlo
desde que yo era chiquito me interesaba
mucho los temas de la actualidad y demás
y a medida que fui creciendo me fue más
interesando a la política y cosas así
entonces he participado varias veces en
el club de naciones unidades de mi
colegio y este año tuve la oportunidad
de ir a hablarlo estuvimos cinco días
debatiendo y pasando sus resoluciones
sobre temas como la automatización del
trabajo y demás pero a mí lo más lo que
más me queda decir a yolanda fue la
gente que conocí gente de mi edad que en
otras partes del mundo y sobre todo la
gente que vive en europa porque todos
ayala o la gran mayoría tenían un
trabajo y se sorprendían un montón
cuando yo les decía que no tenía un
trabajo se extrañaban y me preguntaban
cosas como que porque no has trabajado
nunca tienen mucho tiempo libre y la
verdad esto me me llamó la atención y me
puse a ver que no solo yo no tengo un
trabajo nadie en mi entorno aquí en
ecuador tiene un trabajo no no es algo
que no tenemos una cultura de trabajar
está
pero bueno antes de eso me pregunte a mí
mismo cómo haría yo para fomentar esto
mejor cómo resolverías
lo que hice fue en principio llegar a
ecuador y hablar con mi mamá ella por
suerte me pudo dar un trabajo y lo que
hago con mi mamá es que ya tiene una
fábrica de confección y yo le compro con
un amigo prendas que no vendió de
colecciones pasadas y las vendemos en
mercados y ferias alrededor de la ciudad
y bueno la verdad
como les dije como resolvería ayer es
para mí en primer lugar no fue una carga
intolerable trabajar no fue algo que no
pude hacer fue algo que yo vi que una
responsabilidad más pero yo fui capaz de
hacerlo pero los primeros días fueron
difíciles obviamente me acuerdo perfecto
que antes de la primera feria mi mamá me
dijo mejor dicho más me advirtió que
tenía que estar en la feria a las 9 de
la mañana con absolutamente todo listo y
ya estar vendiendo y yo sabía que tenía
que levantarme a las 6 porque teníamos
que recoger la mercadería teníamos que
pasar por mi amigo y la feria nos queda
un poco lejos de donde digo y yo me voy
a costar pero no tienen ni idea lo
difícil que es para mí levantarme a las
seis de la mañana voluntariamente yo
espero todo toda la semana para dormir
el sábado y no puedo no puedo pero esta
vez lo hice porque porque tenía ganas de
trabajar porque me dieron ganas de no sé
de trabajar y me pude convencer a mí
mismo y salimos de encaminar la feria y
ya una vez recogía las cosas me encontré
con mi amigo ya estábamos llegando la
feria cometimos un montón de errores
obviamente era la primera vez
muchos errores como por ejemplo no
temamos como 30 minutos encontrando
parqueo encontrando donde poder
descargar las cosas y cuando entramos ya
están todos listos y nosotros estábamos
ahí mi amigo y yo con tres cajas de
entrando y todo el mundo comprando y
estamos también muy asustados porque los
primeros 15 minutos nadie pasó por
nuestro stand porque además la manta
gris que ven atrás mío no es una no es
un mantel es una sábana que compramos en
el día porque también se nos olvidó el
primer día es el primer día fue un poco
desastroso pero bueno fuimos aprendiendo
y cada decíamos mejorando y mejorando
y como les dije yo me pregunto a mí
mismo cómo podría yo fomentar este tipo
de trabajo en el color
y el primer paso lógico para mí es verlo
de un punto de vista económico
me puse este análisis más que entrar
profundamente al impacto económico que
tiene un trabajador de mi edad o de su
edad en un país habla más sobre es más
sobre mandar un mensaje para que ustedes
reflexionen un poco sobre lo que es
trabajar a los 16 años
me puse a ver bien economías como la de
estados unidos o la de alemania se
fomenta y se le da la posibilidad a
gente ni de trabajar medio tiempo es
completamente normal es algo que más o
menos la sociedad te empuja a hacer y
eeuu tiene un pib 19 puntos 5 trillones
alemania uno de tres puntos y de
trillones pero obviamente son economías
que están muy lejanas a la nuestra
nosotros tenemos un pib de 104 mil
millones de dólares es lo pueden ver en
la escala que está transmitiendo una
economía mucho más chiquita
y viendo esto me puse a ver a colombia
colombia es un país con una afinidad
cultural y económica mucho más parecida
a la nuestra es un país que tenemos con
el que tenemos historia compartida
y es un país con un pedido más cercano
sin embargo es un país que de todas
maneras tiene un pib de tres veces el
ecuador y me llamó la atención que sea
siendo un vecino y teniendo una afinidad
cultural tan grande esté mucho más
desarrollado de lo que está ecuador
económicamente y me puso a ver y en
colombia se puede trabajar desde los 15
años si tienes un permiso del inspector
de trabajo de tu localidad y se puede
hacer perfectamente
y yo soy consciente que el que trabaja
que el que trabaja yo o alguien de su
edad no tienen el más mínimo impacto en
cómo calcular el pib y el tamaño de la
economía pero sí me parece que hay una
relación interesante entre los
desarrollar esta una economía y cómo ve
esa economía a su gente joven si los de
capaces y los de gente productiva o si
los ve como personas que son niños
todavía y que son incapaces y que no van
a ser capaces de hacer nada
por eso y en ecuador esto es necesario
que pase necesitamos renovar la fuerza
laboral necesitamos que las empresas se
pueden adaptar mejor a las necesidades
del mercado por un horario del medio
tiempo a la que la gente de 16 años
podría entrar y también cuando empiezas
a trabajar se te pasan un montón de
cosas por la cabeza no tiene que ser
ningún trabajo grande por ejemplo abres
una cuenta del banco y si hay muchas
personas de mi edad o de su edad que
abren cuentas en el banco es una
inyección de capital significativa
alcohol a que los bancos no contaban
antes y esto estimula la economía del
país
y bueno hablando un poco ya de la parte
económica me pareció que lo más
importante es el impacto personal de
trabajar y de esforzarte por algo
la palabra clave aquí es ganar porque
cuando tú ganas algo hecho de tu
esfuerzo tú trabajas te esforzaste y lo
lograste es algo mucho muy diferente de
que te lo den a ti cuando tú trabajas te
esfuerzas y te cuesta obtenerlo tienes
una sensación de logro o de orgullo de
haber hecho algo de no estar tirado en
el sofá sin hacer nada y que sólo tienen
20 dólares
y una sociedad que no incentivo este
tipo de sensaciones en su gente joven le
está fallando esa gente jóvenes está
quitando una oportunidad muy grande de
desarrollo y desarrollar su propia
economía
esto me lleva a mi siguiente punto la
responsabilidad que te desarrolla este
este tipo de actividades de trabajar es
porque como te dije que te cuesta te
cuesta obtener tus ingresos
tienes una responsabilidad ahora de cómo
manejar estos ingresos hay muchas
maneras en las que podemos manejar
nuestros ingresos puedes ahorrar por un
viaje puedes comprarte algo que te guste
hacer un regalo o si quieres hasta
aportar en casa
y eso es necesario para nuestro
desarrollo porque tenemos que aprender
responsabilidad y al hacerle una 16 a 18
cuando ya entre comillas de verdad
seamos grandes vamos a estar más listos
vamos a ser más maduros vamos a saber
elegir nuestros pasatiempos mejor a
manejar nuestro tiempo mucho mejor
y por eso es esencial que trabajemos
esta es una edad en la que estamos muy
perdidos y no estamos listos para lo que
es la vida en verdad no no yo no puedo
esperar que una persona de 18 años pueda
tener un trabajo de tiempo completo
pueda vivir solo entender el mundo bien
si él no ha tenido ningún tipo de
experiencia laboral entonces una
sociedad que no fomenta esto le está
fallando a los adolescentes en su
sociedad
yo pienso que el jugador debería poder
legalizar el trabajo por medio tiempo y
fomentarlo a la gente 16 años en
adelante porque primero se desarrolló
desarrollar la economía del país número
2 estás cambiando la manera que tú te
des a ti mismo y tú ves al mundo y
número 3 porque desarrolla tu autoestima
y esta ha sido mi experiencia para mí ha
sido una gran experiencia en la que
aparte de ingresar un poco de dinero he
hecho sobre todo crecer y aprender dar
más de mí mismo y como manejo mi tiempo
porque como la frase está atrás misma yo
esto es verdad la edad no el fin en la
madurez la experiencia las muchas
gracias